I heard that fluoride and toothpaste and drinking water is not the same as the type of fluoride
used in studies showing benefits for teeth. What are your thoughts on this? And the misleading
information on fluoride being good for you is opposed to highly toxic. So I wouldn't dispute that fluoride
you know using fluoride toothpaste and things may be beneficial for your teeth. fluoride is
you know in the classification basically have a heavy mental and it will you know be substituted
as calcium in your teeth and it can make your teeth harder and it can possibly even prevent
cavities. I mean I wouldn't doubt that. Is it the right thing for it? No. Is it toxic? Highly toxic.
So there's no way that you could even put in fluoride treatment on a tooth which I think a dentist
can do that with a topical you know like like they paint on a fluoride treatment on a tooth.
Still it's going to slump off into your system and it's going to act like a heavy mental. It could
cause the blood brain barrier. It can damage neurons. It can be the cause of neuro microglial priming.
They can damage cells. It's going to be stored in fat cells. It can be the cause of DNA damage
and a cause of cancer. So there's no way a person should be using fluoride toothpaste. There's no
way a person should be accepting fluoride from their dentist. I don't care what it does to your teeth
still but fluoride is not the desired nutrient to make your teeth harder. It's calcium in the right
form to help make your teeth more dense and harder. So no way I think fluoride should be used in
human consumption of any kind or human exposure of any kind. It's highly toxic. That's why I
put it in that I'm sticking to it.